visite à son pote qui est d'origine
japonaise il l'aurore visite à l'hôpital
et il vient le voir il dit qu'on a
grandi ensemble on est des potes et d'un
coup le mec qui sert son pote japonais
le cerf fort obtient
donc lui il est un peu dégoûté bon il
appelle il y a la mer du du japonais sa
petite amie qui vient et du côté voilà
votre votre fils et votre mari il est
mort mais il a une dernière volonté mais
je comprends pas le japonais moi il dit
c'est quoi la dernière volonté il a dit
et là il y a la mer est tombé dans les
pommes il dit mais pourquoi il est tombé
dans les pommes ça veut dire lâche-moi
je suis en train d'étouffer
[Applaudissements]